- [Mark] All right, Chyna.
Chyna, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- [Chyna] Oakland.
- [Mark] Oakland?
- [Chyna] Mhm.
- [Mark] And tell me about your family.
You had both your
parents when you grew up?
- My mom died around
when I was like seven.
She died 'cause she...
My dad was beating on her and stuff.
Beating her up and he ended up killing her
so now he's in jail for life.
So really, I had to go on my own
and do everything on my own.
I started at 13, I'm 16 now.
Been doing this three years.
- [Mark] You started
working the streets at 13?
All right, Harmonie and Nina.
So about a month ago,
Harmonie, you and I
did a little talk here.
And you told me your name was Chyna.
You told me some other things
and some of those things you told me
weren't a hundred percent true, right?
- [Harmonie] All of it wasn't true.
- [Mark] Well, some of it was true?
- Some of it was true.
- [Mark] You're working Figueroa?
- Yeah, I was.
- [Mark] Yeah, but you
don't have a 13 year old
sister who's doing this.
And you're in fact, 13.
- My little sister 8 years old.
- Nine.
- No, she nine years old now.
Forgot about that, she getting old.
She back at home.
I'm not even... I'm from Kansas.
Nowhere near Oakland.
- [Mark] You're from Kansas.
- Wichita, Kansas. That's
eight, nine hours for here
on a plane.
So I don't know.
- [Mark] So you ran away?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Where did you run away?
- I started running away
back at home in Wichita
which led me here
to get away from running away
but then I started running away out here.
- [Mark] To get away from what?
- To get away from like, all
that running away and stuff
that I was doing back at home.
I had to come here 'cause it was like,
my mama wants to get me away from
stuff that she knew I
was gon' to keep running.
- Harmony likes attention so
I thought that moving her
out here to LA with me
which was where I was
living at the time...
You know, we've always had
dreams of her going to the
Millennial Dance Complex,
and her dancing with Matt,
Stephanie at that studio.
- [Mark] She's a good dancer?
- Yeah, she's a great dancer.
So I went out there and, you know,
we checked out the studio
and wanted to get her enrolled in that,
and we got her signed
up at the YMCA downtown
and you know, I spoiled her
a lot throughout the time.
You know, she came out here
and she got new everything,
Not tryna punish her for her past,
but trying to just move on from it
and do something different.
- [Mark] What made you want to
run away in the first place?
- Attention.
I mean, not even attention.
Attention, because if I'm not getting-
- Mom works a lot.
- Yeah, she works a lot
so it's like as much as she's worked,
it's like she not doing it just to do it,
she's doing it for a reason.
So her kids have somewhere
to lay their head
and I wasn't getting that
until, you know, I kept running.
She kept having a cry
down to me and tell me
and she rather just tell
without having to cry and stuff.
So, you know, I just chose to come home.
- [Mark] But going to Los
Angeles, going to South central
and working on Figueroa as
a prostitute is a big step
from running away.
- Yeah, it was. See that right there,
I didn't even know what
all that was until I ran.
Like, I ran away for a
couple of days and I was...
I had ran away and went to the
Baldwin Hills Crenshaw mall.
That's where I first
got my first destination
when I ran away.
That was my first destination.
I went there and I met
this light-skinned girl
and we started hanging out and stuff.
She said it was her uncle
house but yeah, I don't know.
So we there or whatever.
And yeah.
But then he had, I think kicked me out
'cause I kept stealing phones
from people and stuff
and going out and stealing
phones from people.
So he kicked me out and
that's when I just started.
I met this dude and I didn't even know
that he was trying to,
you know, be a pimp.
I thought tryna be my
boyfriend or something.
So that's how I was thinking
but then when he showed me the blade
it was like, money was easy.
So I don't know.
I started to do it and didn't like it.
- Then why did you think...
I mean, if you need money,
you know you can call me.
Why would you resort to that?
- It wasn't just money.
It was more than money. It was, like-
- Because you gave him your
money so it wasn't about-
- It was the attention,
and it was the socializing
and people I was around that
was keeping me around it,
not just the money.
'Cause I cannot make no
money all night, you know, so
that's what I was doing mostly,
but I regret it.
- [Mark] For a 13 year old girl,
it's a pretty extreme move.
- Yeah, it is but I'ma
learn from it, you know?
'Cause that's gonna
make me a bigger person.
- [Mark] It will, it will.
- Especially 'cause I was 13.
- [Mark] You're such a
smart and beautiful girl.
You have the whole, you
know, so much potential.
- I know I'm talented 'cause you know,
the acting I did last time.
- [Mark] No but staying on track
and doing the right things in life
are gonna help you do
wonderful things in life.
And going down there and
(chuckles) doing that...
If you watch some of the other girls
that have done what you're doing,
you see where they end up.
It's a tough life.
I don't know if there's
any that have said,
"Yeah, it was a great move
and I'm happy I did it
and I've made a lot of money."
Not one.
- (chuckles) It's not a happy moment.
It's like, every night
you should feel nervous
going out there.
Police driving by you,
flashing their lights
and you're 13, standing right
there it's like, (hisses).
And you're not supposed to be out there
'cause you did just run from
placement, so it's like.
- [Mark] And there's other
girls that age out there, right?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Not a lot.
Not a lot but there's others.
- They probably lie too.
- They probably be more
in the back streets and
out of sight.
(chuckles)
- [Mark] So you guys are
going back to Kansas?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Kansas city, where
you live and Harmonie's father
lives there as well?
So you guys will be a happy
family again, hopefully.
- Trying to get back to that.
- [Mark] That'd be great.
Your girl got a little bit off track.
- A lot-
- [Mark] But you got her back.
- Yeah.
- I been off track since
I left like, fifth grade.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Why do you think that is?
'Cause mom's not around?
- 'Cause I started being
fighting a lot in sixth grade
and I started getting suspended
every day in sixth grade,
which led me to, I think more anxiety
and more depression feeling.
'Cause I don't like being in trouble.
That's just me.
I don't like, you know, punishment.
I'ma find my way to get
out of it as best as I can.
I'ma say whatever I gotta
say to get out of it.
And if I don't get out of it,
that's when I start to get mad
and throw a temper tantrum.
But that was before I just started.
Now I just run.
- [Mark] Yeah, so you were
on Figueroa since when?
- Since like, two months
after I ran away out here.
- [Mark] So that's like
what, beginning of the year?
- No, it's more like May.
- [Mark] Oh, so you've
only been working Figueroa
for a short period?
- It's only been like, three months.
- [Mark] Three months?
- Even though all about Figueroa.
- [Mark] Wow, you seem very
experienced in that talk though,
the first video.
- Really, I only been on Figueroa...
- [Mark] 'Cause some of the other girls
that I've interviewed watch your video
and they say, "That girl is
not, (chuckles) she's not fresh.
She's been around a long
time, you can tell."
- Yeah, that's 'cause I'm a good actor.
- [Mark] Yeah, you are good.
- I told her, I was like,
you had so many other
things to run to in California.
This is like the city where
people's dreams come true.
Could've went and stood
in a Hollywood line
and became an actor if
that's what you wanted to do.
My main concern with Harmonie is,
what does she want to do with her life?
And how can we start to heal from this?
And what can I do
so that you don't leave home again?
Because I'm a mother, I'm
always gonna have to work.
- See working isn't even...
You can work all you need to.
It's just, make time for me too.
- What would you like to do with me?
- Anything. It don't matter
if we gotta watch TV together,
which we don't even
watch TV, but I'll do it.
- [Mark] I think kids just
wanna be with their parents.
You don't need to be going to
Disneyland or anything crazy.
You just need to just be with them,
talk to them, listen.
- We ain't ever gotta be long.
- [Mark] Go for a walk.
- Just a second for me
to feel good, you know.
My mom right here, she here.
- I haven't watched TV with you.
I don't really watch TV but
I'm sorry.
(inaudible)
- But everything gon' be good, just wait.
I should even make a
little video after this.
- [Mark] We should do it down the road.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] In a year or whatever you want.
- Yep.
- [Mark] 'Cause I think you're gonna
do some great things in life.
- It's more like part two, huh?
- [Mark] This is part two.
There'll be maybe part
three, four, five, who knows?
You're only 13.
- I know.
I have a big mind, though.
- [Mark] You do, you're very intelligent.
- I don't know, my intuition to my mind,
to my craziness, to
everything else is like a lot.
- [Mark] Being crazy is not necessarily
the worst thing in the world.
- It's not.
- [Mark] It's not, you can use it as fuel.
I do. (laughs)
- [Harmonie] But my mama,
all that stuff I said
in that video, I regret.
'Cause my mom alive. Alive as hell.
- [Mark] Yeah, you said
your mom and dad were dead.
You said that-
- [Harmonie] Yeah, my daddy, he alive.
- [Mark] You said you
graduated high school.
I don't think you have, right? No.
- [Harmonie] I ain't even...
I'm in seventh grade. (chuckles)
I'm in the seventh grade.
- [Mark] So you're out
of school right now?
- [Harmonie] Look, I ain't been to school
since coronavirus started.
But I don't know.
- [Mark] Well, your mom
came out here to get you.
- [Harmonie] People back at
home know what's going on.
They seen that video.
It's crazy 'cause it's big.
And it's like, I didn't
know it was gon' just like,
get that many views and
everybody was just gon'
come in the store and start asking me
if I'm the girl in the video.
- [Nina] Do you liked that though?
- [Harmonie] I like it that
they coming to me like that
'cause it's attention but I don't like
why they coming to me, the reason.
- [Nina] So you don't like
all attention, or you do?
- [Harmonie] I don't like all attention.
- [Nina] Because that's
not good attention.
- [Harmonie] Yeah, it's
not. That's why I said
I was just gon' do this video
and then it'd be easier for me to respond
to them when they come to me.
- [Nina] Who is your family then?
- [Harmonie] My family is
you and my sister and my dad.
- [Nina] What are they like?
Because your dad is known
as a woman beater right now.
And your mom is know as dead.
- My dad, he ain't never
hit my mom in his life.
Never, ever, ever, ever.
- Me and your dad have
the closest relationship.
- 'Cause my dad and my
mama are best friends.
They ain't dated in 10 years.
They ain't been together in 10 years.
- [Mark] So your mom and dad split up.
- Yeah, they split up when
they had my little sister.
- [Mark] But they still
live together, right?
- No.
- We still raise you guys
in the same household.
- They still raise us in the
same household and everything
but they-
- Are not together.
- They're not together.
Mom went to go work and travel.
- [Mark] But your dad's a good dude?
- Huh?
- [Mark] Your dad's a good guy?
- Yeah, he's good.
- He's really good.
- [Mark] I know your mom cares.(chuckles)
I know your mom cares.
- That's like my twin in emotions.
- [Mark] Your dad?
That's the way it goes.
- And this is my twin, twin-twin.
Like, y'all see it.
- [Mark] You guys look alike, yeah.
- My dad is my twin and
all my emotions in like,
problems I go through, like,
I can relate to my dad.
- So what are some things
that I have taught you
that you are using when you're out there?
- When I'm out there
I'm using my intuition
which you taught me how to use my...
No I came with my intuition
'cause she got a good intuition
which came to me and I hope it
came to my little sister too.
- Who knows.
- And she taught me about a man too.
See, before I started all this stuff,
I ain't even know what
a pimp was, like I said.
- I didn't teach you what a pimp was.
- That's what I said, I ain't
even know what a pimp was.
I was thinking more about
boyfriend and men and stuff,
and she was telling me, well,
a boyfriend isn't really,
you know-
I taught you that a boy is
something you pay attention to,
not your date.
- Yeah, not a date.
A man is something you grow
it and feel it and last.
Wait, and a king...
I feel like that's kind of,
it's not the same thing but
what I just said was a
king more than a man.
- No, I taught you boys are
something you pay attention to.
Nobody wants to date a boy.
He can't do nothing for you.
A man is someone who
you will practice with,
you'll go through relationships.
You will practice with men.
And a king is someone who you will build
and grow with and marry
and have children with.
- Yeah.
- Now you know what a pimp is, though.
- Yeah, that ain't a
man, that ain't a king,
that ain't a boyfriend.
That's just, like...
- It's a lane.
- It's a lane. To be honest like,
- He's making money off of little girls
and telling you whatever you wanna hear
to make you feel good.
- Not even just the little
girls, older women too.
That's why they get beat on
because they keep going back
'cause the stuff that that pimp tell them,
they're gon' keep going back
'cause they feel special.
And that's one thing, I'm not stupid.
I'ma leave.
Even if I was older doing this.
- So
when we go home,
are you going to run away from me again?
- No, I don't plan on running away.
I plan on just staying home.
- Even when it gets hard?
- When it get hard, I'ma be in an activity
so I know when it get
hard and you yell at me
I'ma just be able to go do my track
and it's gonna be all over.
- No, I'm done with the yelling.
I have learned how to control my emotions
since you've been gone
because yelling doesn't
get you to come home.
So I had to learn how
to control my emotions
and learn how to communicate with you.
- I'ma be in activities and stuff
so it's not gon' be no
reason for me to run.
I'ma in track, dance or
whatever I gotta be in
'cause track and dance is
the same team so it's like,
it's all gonna add up when I get home.
- Well, not only are gonna be in act-
- [Mark] You're on the track team too?
- I was last year but I can easily go back
when I go back home.
- I have thing set up
for her at home like-
- Studio, I love rapping.
- Yes, there's a black-owned
network back at home
and they have a television studio.
They have a podcast situation.
They have a radio station and a studio
so she likes to do music,
so she's going to do that.
She's gonna get back involved in sports.
And I'm also gonna be
starting a podcast with her
teaching her about
spirituality, her spirituality,
how to be self-aware of who she is
and why she does the things that she does,
her emotions, how to control
her thoughts, entrepreneurship
and just life as a whole.
- [Mark] That's great.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That sounds really good.
- And because I don't want other children
to go through what she did.
And had I known that my job...
I'm a hairstylist so I travel to do hair.
Had I known that it was affecting
her the way that it did.
- But you see, everybody
was telling you that,
but it's just, you
didn't really understand.
You were just like, "I'm working."
- Sometimes I still don't
understand because I feel like
I leave for a couple of days
to go work while other parents
work two and three jobs
and have to be gone every
day from their children.
- The thing is though, that's different.
At least they're coming back.
- There's people in the army that go
and be away from their children
for a whole year at a time
and their family is at
home supporting them
and their kids are not leaving.
There's the flight attendants.
They're gone from their
children 24 hours at a time.
- Yep.
- There's a lot of people
who work that have to leave.
Even him like, he just-
- [Mark] I've been gone for four days now.
- Right, he just was gone and you know,
we're parents, we have to work.
- I don't know about
flights and army people,
I need my mama.
- I mean, the thing is,
you have to learn how to
find the positive in things
and look at things in
a positive perspective.
Although yes, your mama works
but you've been coast to coast.
You've seen both oceans,
you've ate on the beach.
You know, you've done a lot of things.
- I've been with my
mama while she traveled,
it's just when she
leaves, it's like, dang.
It just all comes down.
- Yeah, not every time you can go.
- It's like, I wanna be with my mom
and that's what it feels like
so when it's like, I can't be with her
and I get so used to can't being with her,
I just feel like, you know,
being on my own, like she do.
I just feel like that's what
she's doing, but it's not.
So that's how I be thinking.
And that's why I be running.
- [Mark] You're a very mature 13 year old.
So it's almost like you're
more like a 16 year old or something
and you actually can think
for yourself, I think.
- I wanna know, attention, like,
at the end of the day we
have to have self-love
and if you're constantly
seeking attention from others
and seeking love from others,
you're not going to be
focused on loving yourself
and giving yourself attention
'cause you paying attention to yourself
is way more important than anybody else
paying attention to you.
- See, when I paid attention to myself,
the most I paid attention to myself
is when I'm on a run.
That's the most when I
pay attention to myself.
When I'm at home, I don't
really pay attention to myself
but I do but I don't.
'Cause it's like, I'm too busy
'cause home is where everybody's at.
So it's like, I be too
busy worried about friends
when I'm at home, not about myself.
- I'm talking about in general,
no matter where you are.
You need to be paying
attention to yourself,
loving yourself, not worried about
who else is paying attention to you.
Like, why do you care so
much about what others see?
Is it social media that's
making you like that?
- I care so much about what others see
'cause of how I am, a
lot of people know me
and that's where most of
my attention comes from.
So if I lose all that, it's like, dang.
- But most of your attention
should come from yourself.
- Yeah, most of my attention
should come from myself
and I'ma work on that.
- We gon' work on that.
- [Mark] Yeah, your mom's
advice is very good.
Loving yourself is gonna
solve about 20 other problems.
- And we can work on it together.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I'm not perfect either.
- [Mark] Yeah, you'll struggle with this
for the rest of your life but-
- She got some years to go too.
- And you're only 13.
So you have plenty of time to change
and you have plenty of time to grow.
- And especially how
much I know now, I got-
- Just use it to the best of your...
Use it, you gotta use it.
- I'ma put it in my music.
- [Mark] Excellent. All
right, Nina and Harmonie.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Thank you so much for coming back
and explaining everything
that really was going on.
- You welcome.
- [Mark] And good luck
getting back to Kansas City
and good luck with your future, Harmonie.
You're an amazing girl.
You're beautiful.
You're smart.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] You're talented.
It would be such a waste if you
went back to that lifestyle.
That's just a waste of time.
- Yep.
- [Mark] There's so many
better ways to live.
- [Nina] Yeah.
Plenty other ways to find happiness
and attention.
- [Harmonie] Yeah.
- [Mark] All right, thanks, you guys.
- You're welcome.